MIKE: Welcome to Google
Atlanta's first Authors
AtGoogle talk.
It's a bit of an accomplishment
for us.
Today, we have Thomas Huynh,
who will be addressing the
ongoing relevance and the
contemporary applications for
Sun Tzu's "Art of War."
Thomas has an MBA from
Vanderbilt University and has
been studying "The Art
of War" for 20 years.
In 1999, he found sonshi.com,
which is now regarded as one
of the foremost resources on the
internet for "The Art of
War." In 2008, his
"The Art of War--
Spirituality for Conflict"
was published.
And this book is his new
translation of "The Art of
War" combined with
his annotations.
Please welcome Thomas Huynh.
THOMAS HUYNH: Thank you, Mike.
I appreciate the introduction.
OK, so I'm going to
get used to this.
Well, anyways, like what
Mike was saying, my
name's Thomas Huynh.
I'm the founder of sonshi.com.
And the title of my presentation
today is "Sun Tzu
and You," because I want to
emphasize the fact that
despite Sun Tzu's being 2,500
years old, it's still relevant
to our modern world.
And at the individual level,
it's relevant to you as well.
So I thought I could
clear up--
discuss the elephant in the
room, what is it in it for you
to spend some time with
me here today?
Well, you'll learn a little bit
about "The Art of War" and
what the big deal is about.
You might have heard about "The
Art of War" through a
newspaper article or maybe
through a friend--
they might have recommend
it to you.
I've heard professors
would recommend the
book to their students.
Well, to me, it's a big deal.
And we'll find out a little
bit about it in our
presentation.
And hopefully you will see
clearly how it can help you in
your life, because we all
experienced conflict and
competition in all
of our lives.
OK, so the flip side of the coin
is, what's in it for me?
Why am I here spending the
time with you here today?
Well, I understand--
I think Mike promised that
Google would change the
algorithm where sonshi.com
would be number one.
Anyways, just kidding on that.
Seriously, this is what
I like to do.
I like to share Sun Tzu's "The
Art of War" to as many people
as possible, because I think the
book can be a big benefit
to everyone who reads it.
And I've been doing this at
sonshi.com since 1999.
And before that, I studied
the book for 10 years.
And so it's been about 10
years since we started
sonshi.com.
And that's pretty much the same
time Google was founded.
That's quite interesting
there.
Having been born in Saigon,
Vietnam, as you know, it's a
war-torn country.
It's better, but it's still
a communist country.
But you can kind of understand
why the subject of war
fascinates me and it's an
important issue to me.
And if all political leaders,
and even tyrants, if they were
to read and understand, and even
apply the book, I believe
that all existing wars
would literally stop.
Literally.
And in fact, all future wars
would be prevented altogether.
So that's how much I view "The
Art of War," and how important
it is in our society.
What this presentation is not.
Thought I'd review it
with you real quick.
It's not about China.
I know it's a hot topic
nowadays, but unless it's
related to Sun Tzu, we're not
going to talk about China.
We're not going to talk about
what are the best translations
out there--
the Chinese characters
and whatnot.
These two subjects-- these two
items, we have very, very good
experts on these two items.
And so some of them are
part of sonshi.com.
My role at sonshi.com is more
of a liaison between the
scholars and the
general reader.
We won't be going through every
concept of "The Art of
War." It'll take
too much time.
This is just to get
your feet wet.
And most definitely, I won't be
changing your belief system
if you have a religion or
something like that.
I won't be trying to do that.
If anything, Sun Tzu's
teachings would only
complement whatever
you believe in.
OK, so this presentation,
there's only
one very simple goal.
And that is to get you
interested and start reading
about Sun Tzu's "The Art of
War." And then perhaps
understand it a little bit and
ultimately apply it to your
life because, again, I believe
it will be a big benefit.
Let's discuss about the
background behind Sun Tzu and
his "Art of War" book.
What we know now as China, back
in 500 BC, it's what they
call the Spring and
Autumn period.
It was composed of 13
separate states.
And Sun Tzu was born
in the state of Qi.
And he was later employed
by the state of Wu.
And he wrote "The Art of War"
kind of like a resume, what
we'd consider a resume now,
to be employed by
the state of Wu.
And so when the ruler
of Wu was reading
this, he was very impressed.
This is his philosophy
on warfare--
how you would approach
warfare.
What became as "The Art of War"
indeed was the earliest
work on military strategy.
OK, so a lot of people, when
they envision Sun Tzu--
excuse me, I'm going to
drink a little bit--
what they envision about Sun
Tzu, they're taking some old
guy with a long beard
or whatnot.
But he was only about 30 years
old when he wrote "The Art of
War."
And you might be thinking, man,
that seems a little bit
young to know anything
about war.
But consider this.
His father was an accomplished
general.
His grandfather was a
provincial governor.
And their entire family is
very focused on military.
So it's not unlike Mozart.
A lot of people think Mozart
is a genius, and he is.
But his father was a worldwide
famous composer.
And his father literally quit
his job to focus on little
Wolfgang, trying to help him
study music and whatnot.
And so by the age of
15, Mozart was
composing his own music.
Well, this is Sun
Tzu at age 30.
And so by this time, you
know that he's studied
all the past battles.
He's gone with his father
to know the inner
workings of the army.
And so--
but of course, the proof
is in the pudding.
Is he competent at that age?
Well, he was hired by
the ruler of Wu.
And what he did was--
the state of Wu was one of the
smallest, if not the smallest,
of all the 13 states.
So they had very limited
resources.
Yet he was able to help them
capture the capital city of
the largest state of
the 13 states, the
capital city of Ying.
And so everybody took notice
after that and said, man, who
is this guy?
I want to know a little
bit about him.
And so "The Art of War" was
treasured from day one.
And so it's never been lost or
burned or anything like that.
You might have heard that
Chinese emperors have a
tendency to burn books,
especially books that counter
to their philosophy.
Well, "The Art of War"
wasn't one of them.
And a lot of Chinese works
have been lost due to
generations, not through
intent but
just through neglect.
But again, "The Art of War"
wasn't one of them.
So it's still with us.
And that's why it's
such a big deal.
Not only is it still
here, it's still
being actively used.
And not only in China, where it
originates, but it's also
here in the United States.
And so I thought to go through
some of where it's being
applied here in America.
War colleges.
No surprise there.
It's a military work.
And so it's being studied at
the Naval War College, the
Army War Colleges.
What might be interesting is
that it's required reading for
all US Marine Corps officers.
And as you know, the Marine
Corps are the
first ones into battle.
And so they don't like fluff.
They like something
that's relevant.
Another principle that they
believe in is "leave no man
behind." Sounds like a very
compassionate principle, but
it's also very effective.
If you think about it, you
have an organization that
values you enough to come back
for you, you're going to work
hard for them.
So anyways, the reason
why I know this is we
interviewed a general.
His name is General
Charles Krulak.
He was the 31st commandant
at the US Marine Corps.
And he tells us that he
installed this policy because
he knows that it would help the
officers out in the field.
Well, here's the bombshell
here, I think.
Not only is it applicable to the
US Marine Corps, but all
of the US Armed Forces.
The current secretary of
defense, Robert Gates, when he
was first hired by President
George W. Bush in 2007, he had
to get in front of Congress and
explain to the US Congress
why he would be different and
better than his predecessor.
And so both in March and in May,
he went in front of them
in public and he quoted Sun
Tzu's "The Art of War." And
right after he cites it, he
says, this is the general
approach to how we will
secure America.
So as you know, his reputation
is second to none now.
He is still the secretary of
defense under the Obama
administration, under a
different political party.
And so I'm glad, obviously,
that he is using Sun Tzu's
"The Art of War" as
a part of his
curriculum to secure America.
It's being studied at the
graduate business schools.
As Mike was telling you,
I received my MBA from
Vanderbilt University.
And in our business strategy
class, we studied two concepts
that came straight out of Sun
Tzu's "The Art of War."
It's really no surprise, because
there are successful
companies that employ Sun
Tzu's "The Art of War"--
especially in Asia, but here
in America as well.
The really documented ones are
Oracle and salesforce.com.
The founder of Oracle,
some of you might
know, is Larry Ellison.
And he quotes the book a lot.
And he really likes the book.
And I think his house is some
sort of Japanese fortress or
palace or something like that.
He actually flew Japanese
craftsmen here to America just
to build his house, because
he has a lot of money,
apparently.
His protege is Mark Benningham,
who founded
salesforce.com.
And Salesforce, as some
of you might know, is
a partner of Google.
And Mark said in one of the
interviews, he says,
salesforce.com would look very
different today it wasn't for
Sun Tzu's "The Art of War."
And I would like to quickly
mention that Mark has a new
book coming out on
November the 9th.
It's called "Behind the Cloud,"
and it chronicles the
beginning days of
salesforce.com.
He will also outline how you can
run successful companies.
So just make sure you pre-order
from Amazon.
And of course, there are other
areas where Sun Tzu's "The Art
of War" is being used, but I
thought I'd put down something
cool and current.
Anybody a hard rock fan here?
Come on, it's OK.
There's a lot more
than you'd think.
OK.
Anyways, Megadeth--
and I don't know if you've
heard about Megadeath.
It's one of the more
famous ones.
The front man--
Dave Mustaine--
his favorite book is Sun Tzu's
"The Art of War." And their
upcoming album is called
"End Game." It's a
reference to chess.
And so to of the songs, he
says, is based off of Sun
Tzu's "The Art of War." So make
sure you check that out
on September the 15th.
OK.
So we talked about famous people
and high-level stuff
like military.
But how does it apply to you
on an individual level?
So what I'll do is I'll start in
general, the general sense,
and then narrow it down
a little bit.
So the logic is this.
We all experience conflicts and
competition in our lives.
And we will continue to
experience competition and
conflicts in our lives.
That, I believe, is true.
So Sun Tzu had experienced war,
which is the ultimate
test of conflicts
and competition.
This is--
you have to win it.
There's no leeway.
There's no second chances,
because you're talking about
people's lives here.
And because Sun Tzu has
succeeded at warfare, the
ultimate contest--
and if anybody has gone through
warfare, you would
think everything else related
to conflict and competition
would be a walk in the park.
And so at the very least,
let's see what--
I'm sure we can learn a thing
or two about it from him.
So let's--
I'm going to narrow it down a
little bit for you, and how
the stuff that Sun Tzu dealt
with are pretty much the stuff
that you guys have dealt with.
And so I'm trying to relate to
what he has gone through to
what you are going through
right now.
He wasn't the CEO.
He wasn't the ultimate decision
maker, as I was
telling you.
He reported to the
ruler of Wu.
But he also reported to a
higher ranking general.
I don't know if you
guys know that.
So he has to work with
superiors, like a lot of us.
And like a lot of us, we have
people reporting to us.
And so he had to motivate
them to--
especially on things that your
employees, your direct reports
don't like to do.
If you think about it, you're
talking about sending--
in his case, you're send people
out into battle to risk
their lives.
I don't think there's any
situation in business that you
have to motivate people
that much.
But if he can handle it, I'm
sure he can teach us a thing
or two about motivation.
He had limited resources.
Like I was telling you, he was
working for the state of Wu.
If he was working for the
largest state, you would say,
yeah, he was successful because
he had vast resources.
But he didn't.
Yet he was successful.
And he also wanted the
boss off his back.
This is something that he
actually talked about in "The
Art of War." He says,
no meddling rulers.
He thinks that the general
has the best
knowledge out in the field.
He doesn't want anybody up in
the ivory tower to tell him
what to do.
So given all that--
the constraints and also
the opportunities--
he had to produce results, like
I think every one of us
are expected to achieve our
goals and objectives.
And so no excuses allowed.
So because he has dealt with a
lot of the stuff that I'm sure
a lot of us have dealt with,
maybe we should listen.
OK, so we're at a stage where
I'm sure you're probably
thinking there are some things
that you've heard about "The
Art of War." And so I'm going
to address two concerns.
One is a very common one, which
is "The Art of War" is
about ruthlessness.
Why are you promoting a
book that's ruthless?
And here's how I feel
about that.
In internet terms, he's a
complete newbie, because
apparently this person has
not read the book.
Probably heard a little
bit about it.
And certainly if that person has
read it, he or she didn't
understand it, because I will
present to you three quotes
from "The Art of War" that
will counter this
ruthlessness claim.
He says the good general
looks upon his
troops as his own children.
I want to clarify
something here.
He's not talking about
treating your
employees like children.
He's talking about treating them
like your own children.
When you're sending them out
into battle, you want to make
sure they're prepared and
that they'll come back.
They're your own children,
for goodness' sake.
So you're always looking out
for their best interest.
The second one is, treat the
captured soldiers well.
This is prisoners of war that
we're talking about here.
This is 1949 Geneva Convention
stuff in a
2,500-year-old book.
And in 500 BC, when Sun Tzu was
living, you have 13 states
fighting for power.
At any time, any one of
them can be attacked.
If there was a time where
ruthlessness is justified,
that was the time.
Yet, he still believes in
this principle, which is
extraordinary.
Do not thwart an enemy
retreating home.
This is him letting his enemy
escape because he believes in
the long term.
He doesn't believe in
the short term.
His thinking is this.
He has already accomplished
his mission
by winning the battle.
There's no point in emphasizing
revenge--
emphasizing the emotional
aspects of things.
Let them go, because long term,
he's not creating any
more enemies.
Short term, yes.
They might be causing him
trouble later on.
But long term, he's not creating
any more enemies and
not inciting hatred.
A lot of cynics might say, the
reason why he's letting them
go is because it's very hard to
destroy them because they
will fight to the death.
But my point is--
my reply to that would be you
can still destroy them because
they'll cause you trouble
later on.
But again, Sun Tzu was
thinking long term.
And I believe this is the
problem in the Middle East, by
the way, because a lot of people
now are so focused on
the short term, killing
as many of
their people as possible.
But they don't realize the
long term, inciting and
creating generations
of hatred.
So Sun Tzu was very well
aware of this.
And I think it would have been
good were a lot more people
can listen to Sun Tzu here.
OK, the second concern might
be about deception.
Yes, "The Art of War" talks
about deception.
And this is--
I'm going to illustrate why it
would still be justified.
OK, scenario number
one is this.
You trick the enemy into not
attacking you through deception.
You're appearing stronger than
you really are, let's say--
something like that.
OK, so that's deception.
Scenario number two is
you're completely
honest about things.
Hey, here, look at me.
And if you happen to be weaker
than your enemy, he's going to
go attack you.
So which scenario
is most humane?
The point I'm trying to
drive here is this.
Deception itself is not bad.
It just depends on
the situation.
And this is analogous to the
game of basketball, because if
you're trying to go for the
basket and you're going to
faint to the right--
and so it draws all of your
opponents to the right.
But then you go into sidestep
to the left to go to the
basket like Michael
Jordan untouched.
That's deception.
Or you can be completely
honest and go
straight to the basket.
And so that would require you to
elbow your way in, knocking
people down.
And if you're lucky, you're
going to get to the basket.
Well, which method is
most effective?
Which is most elegant
and would draw the
least amount of hatred?
OK, so don't get me wrong.
Sun Tzu is all about winning.
But only winning wisely.
Because here's why.
Short term, not at
any and all cost.
When you're presented with an
opportunity to gain victory,
but if it's costly, he would
say, just wait it out.
Make sure the timing's right.
Just wait for the
right moment.
No Pyrrhic victories.
Pyrrhic victories are victories
that you gain--
you still have victory, but
it's going to cost you.
He doesn't believe in that.
There has to be a net
benefit there.
So I thought I'd quote this
from "The Art of War." "To
gain a hundred victories in a
hundred battles is not the
highest excellence.
To subjugate the enemy's army
without doing battle is the
highest of excellence." So by
anybody's account, winning a
hundred battles straight--
I mean, how much better
can you do than that?
That's extraordinary.
But Sun Tzu says, there
is something better.
It's winning without
ever fighting.
I think that's both humane
and smart, because--
here's why.
When you're winning a hundred
battles straight, which is
pretty extraordinary, are you
really gaining all that much--
meaning there's a huge
cost to battling.
There's always a cost.
All you know sure is this-- if
you can win without resorting
to battle, your gains
are full.
And if there's cost, there's
going to be very little cost.
So your gains are
almost all full.
So in business terms, this is
almost like, do you want to
run a big company or
do you want to run
a profitable company?
This is like return on
investment, return on assets,
and capital.
So that's what he's talking
about here.
OK, so just to drive
home the point.
So you have sales of
a billion dollars.
That's awesome.
But what's the cost?
If the cost is a billion and
one, not as impressive.
Sun Tzu starts out "The Art of
War" discussing five factors.
And these are the factors which
would determine whether
you will win or face defeat.
And I thought it would be
interesting to review them
with you here.
OK, the first factor is
the way, or the Tao.
I don't know if you guys
know about the Tao.
This is Sun Tzu's own
definition of
the Tao, or the way.
This is you, your superiors, and
the people who report to
you all on the same page.
You're all aligned to go towards
this single mission.
So if you're all doing
that, guess what?
The chances of gaining
victory is increased.
The second factor is heaven,
which is an environment.
Sun Tzu's heaven is more into
weather, because it's a
military issue.
But in business, it might
be about the US economy,
something you have completely no
control over but something
that you have to deal with.
Ground.
This is your environment,
but it's more immediate.
This is your market,
your industry--
so even though you can't really
control it, you can
maneuver around it, meaning--
Google's not going
to be in clothing
retailing anytime soon.
That's not your strength.
That's not your weaknesses.
It won't accentuate your
strengths or negate your
weaknesses.
You're going to focus
on search.
You're going to focus on cloud
computing, that type of thing.
So it's within your control
in that sense.
OK, so the fourth factor
is the general.
That's you, the leader.
And I bolded it because we'll
discuss it in the next slide.
The fifth factor's law.
This is whether everybody's
trained, whether they've been
practicing in controlling
down expenses.
So that's what law is about.
So OK-- so let's talk about
general a little bit.
This is the leader.
And I thought it would be cool
to highlight this, because I
believe it's the centerpiece
of the five factors.
So here are the five attributes
of general.
Wisdom, credibility,
benevolence, courage, and
discipline.
When's the last time you've
seen something like this?
If someone were to have these
five attributes, would you not
follow this person to the
ends of the Earth?
And if you have these five
attributes, wouldn't anyone
want to follow you to the
ends of the Earth?
And so formally or informally,
CEO or not, if you have these
five attributes, you are
indeed the leader.
And you're helping drive the
company towards victory.
I thought I'd highlight
this as well.
OK, here's another reason why
Sun Tzu can help you.
He also discusses
ego and emotion.
If you've been in business,
and you've been around the
block in business a few times,
you know ego and emotions at
inappropriate levels can
kill your career.
And if you run your
own business, it
can kill your fortune.
And so this is what
Sun Tzu says.
"Those angry will be happy again
and those wrathful will
be cheerful again.
But a destroyed nation
cannot exist again.
The dead cannot be brought
back to life."
What he's saying here is this.
Your emotions and your egos
are all temporary.
And he says don't act upon it
immediately, because if you do
act upon it, those actions
will create permanent
consequences.
Yeah, you might say you're
sorry, but you know nobody
would forget.
But there might be even worse
consequences later one.
He's also saying this.
"Before doing battle, in the
temple one calculates and will
win." This is meaning, if you
have a major decision you need
to make, go to a quiet place
like the grotto over here,
somewhere quiet, because it is
literally impossible for you
to make a rash decision there.
You will be more aligned with
reality, and so you can make
better decisions there.
So the takeaway is this.
You might have a very tough
problem ahead of you.
You might face a
lot of issues.
But Sun Tzu says you can handle
it, because if you stay
calm and cool in a quiet place,
you can handle it.
And even if you don't feel like
it-- because it's worse
enough that you have all
these enemies out there
competing with you.
The worst thing you can do
is become your own enemy.
He also discusses
the environment.
He thinks it's so important
that he devotes two entire
chapters out of 13 chapters
on the environment--
mostly on ground, as I
discussed previously.
So basically, what he's
saying is here.
Study it, know it, and most
of all, adapt to it.
So in these two chapters, he's
discussing about 16 grounds.
And he says, OK, here's
the specific grounds.
Here's the description
of this ground.
Here's how you can react
to it and approach it.
So very specific.
But then he has this chapter
called "Nine Changes"--
nine changes meaning
infinite changes.
He's saying there will be times
when you will experience
something that is
unprecedented--
you've never seen it before.
What he's saying is this.
Do what's most appropriate.
And if need be to be effective,
break the rules to
be effective.
And so the takeaway is this.
Yes, learn from history.
Understand history and
learn from it.
But make sure you use your brain
in unprecedented future
situations.
So I thought I'd conclude and
summarize by putting Sun Tzu
in a nutshell.
And I'll be talking about
three concepts here.
So the first concept is to
control yourself, because
there's nobody else you can
control but yourself.
You can't control
other people.
Certainly, you can't control
the environment.
But if you can control yourself,
you can have
influence on people around
you, weather they're your
friends or your enemies.
You adapt to your environment.
And you know you're adapting to
your environment well if it
accentuates your strengths and
it negates or minimizes your
weaknesses.
And so what it does is it
gives you power and
effectiveness to deal with all
the things you have to deal
with, especially around
other people.
OK, the third one, I think, is
most important-- is you never
sell off your principles.
These are the non-negotiables
that you go
into a mission before.
There's a reason why you're
accomplishing this mission,
but you're not going to ever
touch this non-negotiable
island, whatever it might be.
Here's what he says.
He says, "The general who does
not advance to seek glory or
does not withdraw to avoid
punishment, but appears for
only the people's security
and promotes the people's
interests is the nation's
treasure." What he's saying
here is this.
Set aside your ego.
Set aside your emotions.
Focus on your goal.
Focus on gaining that victory,
because guess what?
Once you get that victory, your
reputation is secure.
It'll take care of itself.
So in other words, and in
Google's terms, you can--
fill in the blank-- or
you can be successful
without doing evil.
And the bottom line is this.
Do what works for you and
vanquish the critics, the
naysayers, and the evil doers,
because the best way to answer
and vanquish a critic is to win,
or obtain victory, under
your own terms.
Anyways, to learn more about
Sun Tzu's "The Art of War,"
make sure you check
out sonshi.com.
We've been doing this for
10 years now and I hope
you can stop by.
Anyways, so this is the question
and answer section.
I know one person
has a question.
But anyways, does anybody
have questions?
AUDIENCE: Well, mine's kind
of vague and broad.
I was just wondering about-- you
mentioned that you think
the principles in Sun Tzu's
book could end war.
So I'm curious to hear you
elaborate on that, I guess.
THOMAS HUYNH: I'm sorry?
The principles are
on war, you said?
AUDIENCE: Could eliminate war.
THOMAS HUYNH: Oh, could
eliminate war.
I think I quoted a few quotes
from "The Art of War" where it
can help end warfare.
But here it is.
I mean, OK, we'll always
have conflicts.
We'll always have competition.
You can't prevent anger.
You can't prevent
a lot of these.
What "The Art of War" does,
and what Sun Tzu is really
good at, is he approaches it
from the reality standpoint.
He's not a tree hugger or
a peace-loving guy.
What he does is he describes
it, he studies it, and by
knowing what conflict and what
causes conflict, he's showing
you how to best approach it--
how to end it, and not only
that, how to prevent it.
Excuse me.
It's not unlike cancer.
You ever seen these cancer
research places, they're
studying the cancer.
They're not talking about all
these things-- well, no.
They're studying the cancer.
They're studying the problem,
like Sun Tzu is
studying the conflict.
That's how you'll get
to the answer.
That's how you'll
find a cure for
whatever is ailing society.
So that's why I believe, even
though it is on the art of
war-- it is on war--
certainly it is about war.
It doesn't just describe war,
but it also gives you a
solution to war.
AUDIENCE: So are you saying that
you believe that there is
an actual solution available
to eliminate war?
THOMAS HUYNH: Oh, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Or you think that this
is just something that
could be figured out
by studying war.
THOMAS HUYNH: Well, I mean, I
think a lot of people can
resolve conflicts and
competition, and succeed at
competition, without ever having
to read this book.
I'm not saying that you
have to read this
book to know the answer.
All I'm saying is this is a way
for you to learn about it
in a more structured manner.
You certainly, through
your experience--
and these are fundamental
truths, as I would say.
It's been tested through
2,500 years.
So by this time, if it's still
being used, there's something
to it that just-- oh,
it sounds nice.
Because like I said, this
is the US military
still using this book.
And it gives them a pretty good
approach as to warfare.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Now, I think that
as a kid I read this book.
It's not really that
long, is it?
It's really approachable.
THOMAS HUYNH: Absolutely.
It is 13 chapters.
And you can literally read
it in an afternoon.
But like a game of Go or a game
of anything, it's very
easy to learn and read it.
I'd say it's straightforward
enough for you to understand
it, but there are some nuances
to it where it
will take some time.
But yes, it's straightforward
enough for you to read it in
an afternoon.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
THOMAS HUYNH: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: I don't know if you're
associated with any
existing book out
there or not.
So maybe it's not a
valid question.
But the last time I tried to
read Sun Tzu, it was actually
quite a heavy read, because the
version that I picked up
had included all the historical
references.
So you're reading it, but then
it's always placing it in
context of everything that was
going on in China at the time.
It made it--
it kind of felt like you
got lost in the book.
Which version would
you recommend?
I know there's several.
THOMAS HUYNH: Yes.
I might be biased, because I
actually have my own version.
That book that Mike was holding
up was created by me
and the editors of sonshi.com,
because we know what that's
like, because that's why we
created sonshi.com in the
first place.
Like I said, I'm more of the
user, the liaison between the
scholars and the
general reader.
As far as--
basically, we have all
of the top scholars--
was it a red book
that you were--
AUDIENCE: Yes, with
the black writing.
THOMAS HUYNH: Ralph Sawyer.
He is part of sonshi.com.
Basically, every scholar that's
ever written "The Art
of War"-- the major ones, the
ones that you see out in the
bookstore-- they have
helped us or are
supportive of our website.
So anybody alive out there--
except Samuel Griffith is
another one, but of course, he
died already.
Anyways, yes.
I know what you mean.
But I think in those type of
books, it's great, because for
someone like me who's read
"The Art of War" so many
times, those type of things
are really great.
But for a beginner, it would be
better to have it annotated.
And that's what a lot of
books are about too.
Something that we've done in
2008 is for every verse, we
actually explain what
this verse means--
and not only that,
but how it can be
applicable to everyday life.
So I understand.
But there are certain people
that really would appreciate
the historical background on
"The Art of War." It might not
be the best book
to start with.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, no.
I got about halfway through
it and I was like--
THOMAS HUYNH: Oh, Ralph Sawyer,
boy--he went to MIT.
He went through Harvard.
You know, so he's a
regular scholar.
AUDIENCE: It was way--
yeah, I think it'd be better
as a secondary reference.
THOMAS HUYNH: Oh, absolutely.
He's great, yeah.
Anybody else?
Oh, yes.
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: So what was your
interest in this to begin
with-- like, how did you sort of
start on this journey that
now you've been doing
for 20 years?
THOMAS HUYNH: Like I quickly
mentioned, Vietnam was a
war-torn country.
And so the subject of war
had fascinated me.
Although, when I was young,
when I first picked up the
book, it wasn't a heavy interest
of mine, because I
was still a teenager
at the time.
But I'll tell you, once I
picked it up and once I
started reading it, you get a
sense that, wow, this is an
incredible book, because not
only does it talk about
warfare, which is--
it turns a lot of people off.
I mean, I can understand
that very much.
But at the same time, the book
has this strange way of
turning it around, say, hey,
I understand this stuff.
I understand the conflict
and the competition.
But here's how you
can approach it
in a peaceful manner.
And that's really what
Sun Tzu is about.
I mean, who else would promote
something like winning without
doing battle?
And say, this is
the best skill.
Never mind about this guy
who's won 100 battles
straight, because he's not the
highest skilled general.
Someone who's--
probably not be as famous,
because he's not winning all
these huge battles.
That's what Sun Tzu--
that's the type of person
Sun Tzu would value.
So a lot of times in the history
books, you might be
hearing about all these great
generals winning all these
great battles.
But a lot of times, you have
to wonder to yourself, are
they really the best?
In Sun Tzu's mind, that
might not be the case.
So in a way, that's how
I got interested.
And then it kind of build
up from there.
And it actually took me 10
years to actually fully
understand it.
Even then, I'm still learning
from other people.
And so after 10 years, this is
in 1999, I started sonshi.com.
And so it's been now a
total of 20 years.
So it's just something that,
hey, this is a great book.
I thought it was
very important.
And so we got together with
a bunch of people.
And so we're still there.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: I noticed the
title of the talk.
The subtitle is spirituality
of conflict.
I was wondering, is that related
to the effect of going
through conflict?
Like, the experience of it on
the individual in terms of
growth and development?
I was curious what
the aspect was.
THOMAS HUYNH: It's interesting,
because that is
the subtitle of my book.
"The Art of War--
Spirituality for Conflict."
You know, it's probably--
the way I was thinking about
it is a lot more mundane.
It's like, OK, so here's
a very tough
topic, which is conflict.
It's something that you don't
normally talk about.
But that's part of life, you
see, because that's-- because
if you win all--
I think there was a "Twilight
Zone" show about this.
This guy was winning
all the time.
And he got so bored.
It's not a very fun
life, but--
conflict is part of life.
And how you approach it--
you can approach it in an angry
way, in a very emotional
and egotistical way.
Or you can approach it
spiritually, which is a lot
more holistic, where you
can kind of separate
yourself from the event.
It's kind of like, hm, how
can I describe it?
It's almost like a video game.
You're presented with all these
issues and problems.
How can you approach it?
And so that's what spirituality
is about.
It's not some metaphysical
stuff.
I'm not into that.
I'm more into the
practical stuff.
AUDIENCE: Right, sure.
But I mean, as a practical
matter, do you address or deal
with the fact that--in my mind,
conflict in some way is
almost like doing strength
training for the muscles is.
It's something that's difficult
that you engage in.
And it, in a way, breaks you
down, but also grows you at
the same time.
To me, I guess, conflict seems
like it could have that effect
on you as a person.
THOMAS HUYNH: Oh, yes.
Absolutely.
I think the worst thing
that you can do--
I have a child.
The worst thing you can do is
to put your kid in a bubble.
That person needs to be
prepared, because--
so when you're experiencing all
sorts of conflicts, kind
of like what Sun Tzu
went through.
The more conflicts you go
through, the better you are at
approaching it--
at fine tuning your approach
to conflicts, especially
intense competition.
And so nobody's perfect
the first time.
And I'm not saying that for you
to master it, you have to
read "The Art of War"--
I mean, this stuff has been
around forever and ever.
But Sun Tzu had his approach.
And he was very successful
at doing that.
And here's how he learned
it through all of his
experiences.
Why don't you learn that and
then, obviously, learn from
your experiences?
That's why he has that chapter,
"Nine Changes." He's
saying, OK, here's what I'm
describing to you--
all these grounds.
But you know what?
Ignore all that if you find
something that is completely
different from these
16 grounds.
And use your brain and do what's
most appropriate, even
if you have to break
the rules.
And that's the beauty of "The
Art of War." He's not into
this dogma or doctrine
type of thing.
And that's the beauty of that
one chapter, is do what is
most appropriate, because you
have the ability to know what
the answer is.
It's just being in a quiet place
and not reacting to it
immediately.
Anybody else?
Come on, these are easy
answers here.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Did you grow
up in Atlanta?
THOMAS HUYNH: I actually--
I was born in Saigon, like what
I said, and I came here
when I was seven years old
to Seattle, Washington.
That's where I got my bachelor's
degree, is at the
University of Washington.
And then later on, I worked
at Georgia Pacific.
They actually have
a GP center.
Their headquarters is
here in Atlanta.
That's how I ended up
Thank you, everybody.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]